before we get to today's episode we'd
just like to give a huge
shout out to our sponsor squarespace
it's brain versus brawn in the ultimate
dinosaur showdown
in one corner we have the giganosaurus
and in the other the troadon
although they lived in two completely
separate eras
if these two creatures were to fight who
would win
which dinosaur would be the strongest
who would have the best tactics and
would this be a fair fight this
is what if and here's what would happen
if the gigantosaurus
battle the troadon before we get to our
fight
let's look at the tail of the tape
the giganosaurus is the brawn in this
fight
it weighs in at over 12 000 kilograms
and
is 12 and a half meters long
even though this creature is massive it
can still run
at 56 kilometers per hour
next we have our brains the troadon
this dinosaur is tiny compared to its
challenger
weighing in at just 45 kilograms and
only two meters in length despite the
troadon having a massive size
disadvantage
does it still stand a chance
being the brains of this battle the
troadon knows that
it can't pick a fair fight with the
giganosaurus
and as we can see the troadon is
beginning to stalk the giganosaurus from
afar
but the giganosaurus is hunting for
something to eat and
is completely oblivious to its opponent
since the troodon is so light on its
feet it's able to sneak up on the
giganosaurus and bite its heels
and now the giganosaurus is toppling
over
since it's so top-heavy even the
smallest nick to its lower body can be
devastating although it looks like the
bite on its heel is just a small wound
the giganosaurus is definitely stunned
the troadon is now circling its prey
getting ready to strike next
until it sees the giganosaurus beginning
to stand back up
as the troadon knows it can't go one on
one against the giganosaurus
it scurries away
now the giganosaurus knows it's being
hunted
and is on the lookout for the troadon
the giganosaurus spots its opponent and
it charges at it
but the troadon starts to run away and
since both dinosaurs
move at roughly the same speed it'll be
a battle
of endurance as the chase continues
it looks like both creatures are too
exhausted to run
they finally stop and are head to head
now it's time for round two but
before we get to that let's take a look
at this episode's sponsor
squarespace are you a blogger
entrepreneur
musician or you just exist in the year
2020
well then you need a website and what
better way to do it than with
squarespace
squarespace provides all the tools
needed to create a stunning looking
website
they have a variety of templates that
can be customized to your liking
whether that means setting up a
storefront page or an easy way to
connect to your social media accounts
squarespace has it to start designing
your perfect website
head over to squarespace.com for a free
trial
and when you're ready to launch your
site go to squarespace.com
what if to save 10 percent off your
first purchase of a website
or domain now let's finish this fight
naturally being the bigger predator the
giganosaurus makes the first move
and tries to chomp the throat on his
head off
but being the more agile creature the
troadon is able to dodge this attack
now the troadon is sweeping around the
giganosaurus and bites the dinosaur's
heel once again
ouch that's gotta hurt the giganosaurus
is down once again
this time with two bites on its ankles
it's having a harder time getting up now
but
wait what's that oh my god a pack of
troadons are coming to help take down
the giganosaurus
this is because these creatures hunt in
packs
so instead of a one-on-one battle this
is now a handicap match
and now the giganosaurus is surrounded
and stands no chance against the pack of
troadons
the troadons are quickly picking away at
the giganosaurus and
claiming their victory although the
giganosaurus was bigger and stronger
it stood no chance against the troodon's
impeccable strategy
and agility so that was
one prehistoric battle
now what would happen if a megalodon
fought a mosasaur well
that's a story for another what if